la líder prodemocracia aún sang soo choo
compareció este lunes de manera virtual
ante un tribunal tenía una apariencia
saludable según informó su defensa su
chip no ha sido vista desde que fue
detenida tras el golpe del pasado 1 de
febrero desde entonces está acusada de
violar normativas comerciales y
sanitarias pero este lunes fue imputada
con dos cargos más incitar a disturbios
públicos y violar una ley de
telecomunicaciones
mientras sucedía su audiencia la policía
dispersaba con gases lacrimógenos y
granadas paralizantes nuevas protestas
en el país cientos de manifestantes
salieron a las calles a pesar de la
violenta represión del domingo que dejó
al menos 18 muertos por disparos de las
fuerzas de seguridad es realmente
horrible han demostrado que pueden hacer
cualquier cosa sabemos por su historia
que su brutalidad no conoce límites
vemos que refuerza en esta brutalidad
contra los manifestantes pacíficos creo
que necesitamos sanciones más fuertes
que no sólo sancionar a las personas
sino que también deben sancionar a sus
intereses comerciales y sus diversos
conglomerados el domingo marcó un punto
de inflexión en la represión iniciada
tras el golpe de estado que ha dejado
más de 1000 personas detenidas según
indica una ong local
como saben lo que está haciendo la junta
es ilegal los ciudadanos deben
protegerse
en todo el país los manifestantes
continúan exigiendo el regreso al orden
constitucional así como la liberación de
succi quien enfrentará su próxima
audiencia el 15 de marzo